today's speed round brought to you by
verizon
5g built right all right let's get to it
peter and
there's trouble brewing in seattle not
just coffee
and i didn't mean that but i'll take it
let's hear from russell wilson
speaking to the media yesterday about
the fact that brian schottenheimer
is out and a still to be determined
offensive coordinator will be in here's
russ
you know super important you know i
think that uh coach carol and i you know
we have to be on the same you know
uh same way think we've got we've been
you know able to talk obviously over the
past three days
coach carol and i um you know about a
lot of different things and everything
else and really trying to figure out
okay
you know how far can we go where are we
going what's the plan and then all that
stuff and so
i think a lot of it um you know for me
and coach to really hopefully be able to
partner on the
thought process of the next person and
really that person really being able to
help impact this football team this
organization really
um be a great coach for us and help us
lead us lead us to uh
help you a part of leading us to the
promised land obviously
look russell wilson can smile all he
wants but the words say it all
russell wilson did not want brian shot
and harmer to be fired
russell wilson does not want to go back
to ground and pound and legion of boom
russell wilson wants to showcase his
skills and it was happening this year
until it wasn't
because brian schottenheimer didn't
pivot once defenses figured out
the let russ cook anti-recipe
russell wilson wants to earn his money
russell wilson wants to throw it around
like aaron rodgers patrick mahomes and
josh
allen he doesn't want to be a guy who
hands it off and runs it and throws play
action
he he wants to be one of the marquee
quarterbacks in the nfl
and peter they're paying him 35 million
a year and his contract is going to be
up after three more seasons he's going
to want market value then
if they're not using him why would they
pay him market value
why would he want to stay i'm telling
you if they don't hire a coordinator
that gets the most out of his talents
this thing is moving toward russell
wilson
going somewhere else
i don't know i mean the way i sort of
look at this
situation in seattle is that
you know this team was a totally
different team
down the stretch of this season you know
they struggled
mightily to score in the last four weeks
and my feeling is that it even though
this is a
good run blocking offensive line john
schneider's got to go to work and find
a pass protectors on this offensive line
uh you know because russell wilson just
was so
incredible he was chased down the last
month of this season
more so than you know look i don't know
what the quarterback pressures are i
know every time they play the rams
he gets pressured out the wazoo and
my feeling i think that russell wilson
long term really is going to need a
better pass blocking line
if they're going to maximize his skills
so that
to me is as important as who they hire
as offensive coordinator
they've never had a good pass blocking
line and they just extended the guy
who's responsible for getting the
players i'm
look and i'm having a little fun here
with john schneider obviously he's done
a great job and one of the best things
he did was find russell wilson with a
third round draft pick in 2012.
but i can't help but wonder peter
whether or not at some level
john schneider is longing for the days
of having a quarterback under a rookie
contract
and not under a top of the market deal
because when did they go to the super
bowl when did they go when russell
wilson was operating under his rookie
contract
that's when they went two straight years
when russell wilson was in year two and
three
of his initial deal and since then it's
hard to put a team around him
when he's making first it was you know
it was low
20s now it's 35 and when he's up again
it's going to be 45 to 50. my point is
this
if you aren't getting the most out of
him and if pete carroll wants to run the
ball run the bone he said it this week
we need to run better we need to run
more if he wants to have a run-based
offense and a great defense if this is
old school pete carroll bud grant his
mentor
i you can't justify paying russell
wilson
huge money and look this is something
sims and i were talking about yesterday
sims had heard the rumors before the
2018 draft that the seahawks were toying
with the idea
of offering russell wilson to the browns
for the first overall pick
the seahawks thinking about getting josh
allen what a different team that would
be what a different world that would be
but you just i will not rule out the
possibility when the quarterback is
openly talking about how he wants to be
involved in selecting the next offensive
coordinator
that is a message to the team and if
they ignore it
they're going to have a problem you know
this team ran
like 39 40 percent of the snaps this
year
and if you were rushing for 4.8 to carry
which they were
and i'm pete carroll and i see my
quarterback running for his life
it's no revolutionary statement to say i
want to run more
why why is that why is that so strange
i would run i would want to run the ball
five times more per game
if i'm running for 4.8 to carry and if
my quarterback who has been the most
sacked quarterback in football
since he walked in the league continues
to get the tar beat out of him every
week
so i i mean i don't think not only do i
not think it's a revolutionary statement
i think it is a smart statement and i
think this team would be much better off
if they were 45 to 55
run pass ratio uh rather than being
you know 40 60 or 39.61
i i say the exact same thing i mean look
i don't know what the future russell
wilson is
he's not going anywhere right now i
doubt he's going anywhere
at any time but i think
that you know i i i go on and i say if
anything russell wilson
is underrated and i say that because he
started
every game since he walked on campus
being picked in the draft five spots
after
a punter and he's never
not started a game for seattle since
that day
and you know they haven't had a losing
season since he's been there
to me i think this is about a better
supporting cast particularly up front
i'm going to call my shot and say he'll
be gone by 2025 and i'll put the finest
bottle of mad dog on it peter if you
want to take that wager
i'll i'll take it but i mean look i i
have no idea who
i'm not how do i know i'm going to be
alive in 2025
yes how do you know i'll probably
any of us ever live in 2025 but
but listen mike listen mike if i win
and russell wilson is the starter
opening day for seattle in 25
and i'm not here you have to give ann
king the bottle of mad dog
all right deal uh just make sure chuck
doesn't drink it
all right uh let's speed through these
remaining topics in the speed round
it was a great conversation it was good
to get it delve into these things with
the seahawks the steelers
they're not going to have randy fitner
back as offensive coordinator
contract not renewed peter
it feels like they're kind of edging
toward major changes in pittsburgh
yes i think they should be major changes
and i don't just say this because of the
last game of the season
i say it because of the last month of
the season you know
this team look they keep waiting and
waiting
and waiting and waiting for james connor
to be this
this super back okay james connor just
can't
physically take the toll of being
on every down back he's always there's
something always a little bit wrong with
him
so and again i'm not saying get rid of
james connor but i'm saying you better
get a really good back in there to help
him carry the load
so it's like a cleveland situation but
i think the larger question is you see
ben roethlisberger with the tear coming
down his cheek
after the game last sunday night and i i
started to think what is going through
ben's mind is this it
is my last game ever and it was
unceremonious to say the least
but it doesn't always end well for
heroes and
my feeling is the steelers have to think
very seriously
of a plotting old quarterback
who certainly looks like he'd be better
if he was 20 pounds lighter
they have to think about whether they
want that quarterback
to be their guy going into the 2021
season
and if not are they going to draft one
or are they going to give
uh you know give a kind of a shaky
i would say you know back up a chance to
win the job full-time
but i think it's time to think about the
future ben roethlisberger
well he's got to think about his future
too with fake nergon new offensive
coordinator do i really want to deal
with that again who's it going to be
how many changes are too many changes
for me to think i've got a chance to win
a super bowl and walk off into the
sunset and that's what i've got to be
thinking of 2005 jerome bettis
can ben rothersberger pull that off in
his last season
if he doesn't believe he can there's no
reason coming back for another season
in miami tuatanga viloa already been
declared the starter for 2021
last week gm chris greer said it three
unnamed players told armando salgueiro
the miami herald they're not sold on
touah
brian flores the coach of the team said
yesterday he's excited about the future
with tua
peter should he be
there's absolutely no way unless you
luck
into a trade with houston for desean
watson
and it would be the luckiest thing that
could ever happen to the miami dolphins
since they picked dan marino in 1983 at
the end of the first round
they they have to be excited about tua
fifth pick in the draft
everything is on his shoulders he needs
a regular off-season program and i don't
even know if you're going to get one of
those this year
he needs a regular off-season program he
needs to throw
to his receivers a lot this summer
and he needs to get on the same page
totally with them
and look in some ways tuatanga veloa had
what is a very
normal rookie year for a highly drafted
quarterback
it's just that the comparison to two
guys who played like
terry bradshaw and dan fouts uh you know
in the
who were picked is sandwiching him in
the draft this year
you know obviously that hurts tagawaloa
and and so i but i in no way would want
to give up now
i would have started if he didn't have
covet i would have started fitzpatrick
at miami
at buffalo in the season closer but
that's that's neither here nor there now
i'd definitely give to a
a real shot in 2021
and don't even think about doing
anything else
but i agree with you if they have an
opportunity to get to sean watson you
take that and you run with it if that's
how
dumb has fallen in houston all right
colts general manager chris ballard has
indicated that they'll talk to philip
rivers in a month or so about what he's
thinking
he points out there's a difference
between drafting a quarterback and
drafting the right quarterback look and
you need
the right quarterback you don't just
take the next guy that happens to be on
the board
you want to be sure that he's the right
guy for your team and the colts are just
they're fascinating ever since the
retirement of andrew luck it was jacoby
brissette and then it wasn't
now it's philip rivers will it still be
philip rivers can they get carson
defense
who else is out there that they may get
but this is a very good team
they're just kind of cycling through
quarterbacks waiting to find the one
that's going to stick peter
and i think balor's message is we're
going to keep
going with veterans until we believe
that there is a young quarterback that
is worth burning that first round pick
on or trading up to get a better spot to
go get him
we'll just go the veteran route and this
is a new dynamic in the nfl but i think
it's here to stay
a lot of veteran quarterbacks available
in free agency
as teams realize younger quarterbacks
coming into the league better than ever
offense is adjusting to fit their skills
you can throw them in right away
that creates more veteran options and i
think that's what the cults are going to
keep doing until they find that right
guy in the draft
i think there's a couple of things at
play here number one
the end of the year convince them that
they absolutely unequivocally can win
and go far into the playoffs
with philip rivers so that's that's
number one i think number two
though is that in setting the bar at 25
million
per year for your starting quarterback
you've got a lot of guys on that team
who very soon are going to need to be
paid
you have to decide if you were going to
do
25 million for him or if you're gonna do
what john elway did with peyton manning
before his last
year in the nfl and again i have no idea
if this
did something to the long-term
relationship with peyton manning and
john elway
but remember mike in 2015 peyton manning
was due 20 million
and elway went to him and said i want to
lower your contract to 16 million
in base salary and make four million
achievable bonuses
uh achievable incentives and i want to
go out and sign a guard to make us
better
they signed evan mathis didn't really
work out but
peyton manning had his contract lowered
by 20 and he goes on to win a super bowl
he makes the money back
but you got to wonder what he really
felt about that deep down
now what if you are the indianapolis
colts you're chris ballard and you say
hey the cap's probably going down this
year you'll know about that
right in you know in in mid to late
february
you'll know what the new cap number is
going to be
around that time and so i wonder if the
colts are going to wait till that time
to see where it is
and then say to rivers we can only pay
you 20 million this year
and we're going to take then we'll
phillip rivers will philip rivers
say at that time mike will he say
i'm going to start coaching my kids in
football now i'm retiring
or will he say i'll take the money or
will he say
i'm not signing with you i'll go
somewhere else and my line of
demarcation to play this year
is 25 million i don't know what he'll do
but i do think there's a decision to be
made for the colts
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports